Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir schauen mal wieder auf die Premier League und fragen uns, was passiert da alles so in England? Diese Frage kann uns nur einer beantworten, Thomas Böker vom Kicker, der jetzt hier im 102. Kurzpass zu hören ist. Thomas, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Ich freue mich mal wieder mit dir, über die Premier League sprechen zu wollen. Und da gibt es auch schon zwei übergeordnete Themen, jetzt jenseits von irgendwelchen Vereinen, die interessant sein könnten. Was ist denn dann neu in der Premier League?
Ja, zum einen wurde jetzt beschlossen, dass es ab der Saison 2019-20 dort auch den Videobeweis gibt. Und zum anderen bekommt die Premier League eine neue Chefin. Richard Skardemore hört nach 19 Jahren auf. Und Susanna Dinec, so heißt die Dame, wird seine Nachfolgerin. Die kommt aus der Medienbranche, Geschäftsführerin in einem Medienunternehmen, Discovery und Präsidentin vom Animal Planet Channel.
Das ist ja ganz nah am Fußball dran.
Genau, ja. Das ist auch manchmal eine verrückte Welt. Nein, aber die probiert jetzt offensichtlich mal was Neues. Und eine dreiköpfige Jury hat sie bestehend aus Figuren aus der Liga heraus benannt. Und mal einfach abwarten, was sie für neue Impulse bringt. Und ob sie die Liga da voranbringt. Die Messlatte ist recht hoch, weil die bekanntlich ja sehr, sehr viele Milliarden aus den Fernsehgeldern kassieren, die Vereine dort. Und ja, sowas muss erst mal ausgehandelt werden. Und sowas muss dann auch erst mal auf diesem Level gehalten. Beziehungsweise, das wird natürlich dann erwartet, in drei Jahren noch weiter gesteigert werden. Aber jetzt muss sie erst mal beginnen. Und wird dann nächsten Monat starten in der Premier League. Und was den Videobeweis angeht, war ich sehr überrascht. Weil in den Pokalwettbewerben, wo das getestet wurde, war die Resonanz eigentlich sehr, sehr schlecht. Also es gab ein Chaos, also noch größeres Chaos, als in der Bundesliga. Ja, weil da wurden irgendwelche Linien dann tatsächlich gezeigt, die es ja in Deutschland angeblich nicht gibt. Und das Problem war, dass diese Linien, sagen wir mal so, nicht gerade parallel zu irgendwelchen Schlafraumlinien oder sonst was verliefen. Also sehr, sehr merkwürdig gezogen und dementsprechend auch nicht nachvollziehbar. Dann kam auch hinzu das gleiche Problem wie in der Bundesliga, dass eben die Leute im Stadion nicht so richtig wussten, was wurde denn jetzt gerade überprüft. Das hat sich ja in Deutschland so ein bisschen normalisiert, auch wenn es da auch jetzt teilweise recht spät eingeblendet wird, aber immerhin. Aber unabhängig von diesen technischen Sachen sehe ich in England das Problem oder bin etwas skeptisch, weil der Fußball in England ist noch viel, viel traditioneller und traditionsbewusster als in Deutschland. Und aufgrund seiner Geschichte und aufgrund vieler Vereine, die es schon sehr, sehr lange gibt, und da den Leuten so etwas wie den Videobeweis eben ans Herz zu legen und damit offen und positiv umzugehen, das könnte eine sehr, sehr große Hürde sein. Auf der anderen Seite, was dafür sprechen könnte, ist, man glaubt es kaum, aber in den Stadien selbst sind die Emotionen nicht ganz so, kochen nicht so hoch wie in Deutschland, sodass der Vornehmer Engländer an sich damit vielleicht dann etwas, etwas gelassener umgeht in dem einen oder anderen Fall. Aber insgesamt glaube ich, dass viele das Ganze jetzt mit Skepsis begleiten. Aber das ist bei Videobeweis halt so, manche finden es gut, weil er vielleicht manches gerechter macht, andere finden es schlecht, weil er den Charakter des Spiels ein bisschen verändert. Und das wird dort nicht anders sein. Und man darf gespannt sein eben, wie die Vereine und vor allem die Zuschauer darauf dann reagieren.
Da sind wir mal gespannt, ob sich dann ein englischer Ableger von Colinas Erben gründet. Bin gespannt.
Und ob es den Londoner Keller gibt.
Oder vielleicht den, keine Ahnung, was wir noch so haben. Viele kommen ja aus London, den einen Keller vielleicht auch irgendwo an der Südküste. Da sind ja auch einige freie Brightener Keller oder so. Mal gucken, was sich da etabliert oder ob die da ganz vorne irgendwo sitzen im Landenei, ihre Runden drehen. Keine Ahnung. Wir werden es sehen.
Wir werden es sehen. Und noch kurz zur neuen Premier League-Chefin. Also zum einen natürlich bemerkenswert, dass es eine Frau ist und für den alten Geschäftsführer Richard Scudamore gibt es noch mal einen kleinen Bonus. Da hat der Chelsea-Vorstand Bruce Buck alle anderen Premier Clubs gebeten, man könne ihm doch zum Abschied noch mal jeweils 250.000 Pfund schenken. Insgesamt summiert sich das dann auf 5 Millionen Pfund. Das ist doch mal nett. Also so wie die Teekasse rumgeht, wenn ein Kollege einen verlässt und dann kriegt er irgendeinen Amazon-Gutschein oder was anderes. So kriegt er mal eben 5 Millionen Pfund und da sehe ich jetzt auch überhaupt nichts Bemerkenswertes dran. So sollte das doch sein. Er hat ja sonst nur 2,83 Millionen Euro im Jahr verdient.
Genau, da muss man eben das natürlich auch noch oben drauf gönnen und ja, es zeigt die ganze Perversion des Geschäfts.
Schon ein bisschen.
Und mehr muss man dazu eigentlich nicht sagen und still den Kopf schütteln. Und ja, ist natürlich richtig, was du sagst, bemerkenswert, dass es eine Frau ist, aber genauso rum kann man natürlich auch sagen, dass das noch bemerkenswert ist.
Da hast du tatsächlich recht. Ja, genauso traurig. Damit können wir eigentlich auch mal mit den Manchester-Clubs anfangen. Zumindest einer von beiden ist sehr traurig. United hat das Manchester Derby verloren am letzten Spieltag mit 3 zu 1 bei City. Bevor wir über City sprechen, die immer noch ungeschlagen sind und da aber trotzdem nicht einsam ihre Kreise an der Spitze ziehen, lassen wir auf United blicken. Tabell im Platz 8, 4 Niederlagen jetzt schon, 20 Tore geschossen, 21 kassiert, das heißt ein negatives Torverhältnis und schon 12 Punkte weg von der absoluten Tabellenspitze. Was ist da los bei United?
Ja, da stimmt einiges nicht. Angefangen beim Verhältnis zwischen Trainer und Mannschaft. Es ist eine Zweckgemeinschaft, die sich da zusammenhält zwischen José Mourinho, man kann fast sagen, auf der einen und seinen Jungs auf der anderen Seite natürlich nicht so krass, dass jetzt irgendwie 25 Spieler gegen ihn sind. Das würde dann überhaupt nicht mehr funktionieren. Aber es ist schon so, dass da nicht die größte Harmonie herrscht und wenn dann natürlich auch so ein Führungsspieler wie Paul-Paul Pogba dauernd von ihm in den Senkel gestellt wird, auch öffentlich, obwohl er auf der anderen Seite genau um dessen sportliche Bedeutung für die Mannschaft auch weiß, ist das Ganze schon recht widersinnig. Und das ist das eine dieser atmosphärischen Störungen, die nicht unbedingt dazu beitragen, dass eine Mannschaft ständig an die Grenzen geht.
Aber andererseits haben sie ja doch zum Beispiel bei Juve 2 zu 1 gewonnen und ja glücklich im Zustand gekommen. Ja, sehr glücklich. Aber ich finde, einen Zusammenhalt hat man da schon sehen können.
Einen Zusammenhalt der Mannschaft, ja, das glaube ich schon. Manchmal, das ist vielleicht auch Mourinhos Masche, dass er da so ein bisschen so provoziert, also ihr alle gegen mich und dann haltet ihr zusammen. Was mit mir ist, ist völlig wurscht. Kann schon sein, dass das Teil seiner Intention ist. Aber trotzdem, irgendwann reizt sich diese Art, eine Mannschaft zu führen, natürlich auch aus. Und dass der Sieg bei Juventus, also da muss man echt keine zwei Worte drüber verlieren, weil das war eine der glücklichsten Erfolge, die ich je gesehen habe. Und der einzig und allein Juves Nachlässigkeit geschuldet war, zunächst vorne, weil sie den Sack nicht zugemacht haben und dann, weil sie noch bei zwei Standards gepennt haben. Und ja, hört sich toll an, 2 zu 1 bei Juventus, wenn man das ganze Spiel gesehen hat, muss man sagen, United kann froh sein, da nicht 0-3 verloren zu haben. Das würde ich also nicht überbewerten, trotzdem ist es natürlich für sie sehr, sehr wichtig, dieser Sieg gewesen, weil sie jetzt dann dadurch mutmaßlich in der Champions League eine Runde weiterkommen, was dann wiederum auch etwas mehr Ruhe für Mourinho bringt. Und wie gesagt, die Atmosphäre ist das eine, das andere ist eben das rein Sportliche und da glaube ich, dass United eine Mannschaft hätte oder eigentlich einen Kader hat, mit dem man ganz anders Fußball spielen könnte, nämlich mit viel Tempo. Wenn ich Rushford und Linkart zum Beispiel nur sehe oder Marcial, da kann man unheimlich, könnte man viel rausholen, aber wenn man natürlich ständig erstmal Safety First spielt und beim FC Bayern würde man halt sagen, mehr für mehr und genau dieses Gefühl könnte man bei Manchester United natürlich auch ohne Weiteres aufbringen, das ist der Rekordmeister und der erfolgreichste Verein aller Zeiten in England und die müssten eigentlich schon so auftreten, dass sie in jedem Spiel sagen, wir sind hier die Chefs und die anderen müssen sich nach uns richten und in Wirklichkeit ist es halt so, dass sie es zulassen, dass sie sich nach dem Gegner richten, weil sie eben sehr tief stehen zur Wahl und zu was sie dann im Stande sind, wenn sie müssen, das hat man gesehen, als sie 0-2 gegen Newcastle zurückgelegt haben und dann wirklich mit richtig gutem und erfrischendem Offensivfußball da noch 3-2 gewonnen haben. Spätestens aber glücklich, aber eben auch dann verdient. Und das steckt in der Mannschaft, das schlummert in der Mannschaft und das will, glaube ich, irgendwie losgelassen werden. Und wenn man jetzt bedenkt, dass die seit 2013 nicht Meister waren, dass sie 2008 zuletzt die Champions League gewonnen haben, das ist für so einen Verein, der, glaube ich, nach Real Madrid die zweitgrößte Marke an sich in der Welt, in der Fußballwelt darstellt, ist das eigentlich einfach enttäuschend. Und man hat ja Fehlgriffe gehabt bei den Trainern nach Ferguson, angefangen mit Moyes. Van Raal sehe ich immer so ein bisschen positiv wie negativ auf der einen Seite, so war es bei Bayern auch, bringt er Struktur ins Spiel, davon profitiert Bayern noch heute. Auf der anderen Seite ist er natürlich auch nicht unbedingt einer, der jetzt, ja wie soll ich sagen, für die große menschliche Wärme steht, der eben dann auch für das harmonische Ganze da präsentieren kann. Und all sowas spielt dann natürlich auch im Zusammenhang mit den Fans rein und die waren jahrelang Entertainment gewöhnt und bis hin zu berühmten Fergie-Time in der 96. Minute. Ja, mittlerweile, Old Trafford ist manchmal halt nur noch traurig, was da zu sehen ist. Und das ist einfach schade, wenn man sehen muss, was aus diesem Verein, der ja weiterhin fast unbegrenzte finanzielle Möglichkeiten hat, wenn man sieht, wo die im Moment stehen und das ist halt leider kein Zufall, weil sie eben ja viele Fehler gemacht haben. Aber der Kreislauf ist halt auch klar, die absoluten Top-Spieler, die gehen eben auch dann jetzt unter diesen Voraussetzungen nicht mehr dahin.
Ja, das wird mich jetzt mal interessieren, Thomas, weil die Probleme von United, ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir das jetzt im dritten Kurzpass nacheinander hören, weil du bist dir da einig mit all den anderen Experten, die da zur Premier League zuletzt im Rasenfunk mit dabei waren, wo die Meinungen aber durchaus auseinandergehen, meiner Beobachtung nach, ist eben bei der Bewertung dieses Kaders. Also ich habe einen englischen Journalisten, ich glaube vom Guardian gelesen, der getwittert hat nach dem Manchester Derby, die größte Leistung Morinius sei es, uns weiß zu machen, dass man mit diesem Kader kein Spitzen-Team sei in der Premier League und es gar nicht besser ginge. Und gleichzeitig habe ich einen anderen Tweet gesehen, der kam so eher aus der Fan-Richtung, da hat jemand geschrieben, mit dem Kader bist du auf jeden Fall eigentlich in den Top 3. Und ich bin mir da selber nicht so ganz sicher, da ist unbenommen, ist da viel Qualität mit dabei. Zum Beispiel im Tor mit De Gea und die Innenverteidigung, du hast auch schon auf das Tempo angesprochen, was nicht genutzt wird. Aber zum Beispiel finde ich im Mittelfeld mit Matic, Pokba, Fré ter Réa, Fellaini, McTominay, Juan Mata, Andreas Pereira, das ist alles gut, aber nicht automatisch, finde ich spitz und du deutest es ja jetzt auch gerade an, dass sich so ein bisschen im Kader die absolute Spitze nicht mehr findet.
Genau, ja, absolut, also das angefangen, da können wir auch die Innenverteidigung mit einbeziehen, Smalling und Lindelöf, das ist nicht internationale Klasse. Auf den Außenpositionen, Ashley Young zum Beispiel, ist da eigentlich auch eine Notlösung, er ist links, jetzt sogar rechts. Das ist natürlich nicht höchste Qualität verglichen mit zum Beispiel Man City oder auch internationalen Top-Klubs wie Juventus oder so, oder Barca.
Und woran liegt das? Denn die finanziellen Mittel sind ja noch da, wollen tatsächlich die Spieler nicht mehr zu United? Oder ist Mourinho da seinen ganz eigenen Weg gegangen und seine Vorgänger vor ihm auch schon? Kannst du mir das erklären?
Naja, also wir können es ja konkret an einem Beispiel festmachen mit Boateng, der offensichtlich dort großes Interesse hervorgerufen hat.
Also welcher der Boateng ist?
Jerome Boateng, ja, ja, weil wir sprechen ja gerade über die Abwehr auch. Und ne, ne, das, nein, Jerome Boateng, klar. Und letztlich, ja, war, glaubte er nicht, dass er seine Ambitionen, dass seine Ambitionen mit denen von United deckungsgleich sind, sprich, dass er mit dem Kader absolute, die absolut größten Titel eben gewinnen kann. Und das sagt dann schon vieles aus, weil mutmaßlich, ich weiß es nicht, aber mutmaßlich sage ich jetzt einfach mal, der hätte in Manchester mehr Geld verdient als bei Bayern und ist trotzdem, obwohl ja auch von Bayerns Seite Fahndungsbereitschaft signalisiert wurde, also die hätten den Wechsel, glaube ich, nicht verhindert, ist er da geblieben, weil er letztlich nicht dorthin wollte. Und so geht es möglicherweise einigen gehen. Und ja, dann kommt eins zum anderen und wir reden über keinen schlechten Kader. Wir reden aber auch über einen Kader, der nicht eben das Niveau hat, was im Moment Man City, Liverpool und Chelsea gerade in der Breite eben anbieten können. Vor allem Man City und Chelsea dabei. Die sind besser als Platz 8. Normalerweise gehören die schon in die Top 5, aber da eben dann auch nur auf Platz 4 oder 5, würde ich sie jetzt mal einordnen. Aber Manchester United hat nichts auf Platz 8 verloren. Da spielt dann das rein, was ich gerade gesagt habe, diese zum Teil schwer nachvollziehbare Spielweise. Aber der Kader ist auch nicht so, dass ich sagen muss, oh wow, die müssen jetzt die Premier League an die Wand spielen.
Okay, hat Jerome Boateng ja im Nachhinein auch alles richtig gemacht. Er ist jetzt bei einem Tabellen-5-Platzierten und ist nicht zum Tabellen-8-Platzierten gewechselt. Da kann man einen Haken dahinter machen. Dann lass uns über das andere Manchester-Team sprechen, nämlich City. Da sehen die Zeichen ganz anders aus. Es gibt immer noch drei Teams, die ungeschlagen sind in der Premier League nach zwölf Spieltagen. Und City führt diese drei Teams an, weil man selbst schon zehnmal gewinnen konnte und nur zwei unentschieden bei 36 zu fünf Toren. Das hört sich alles sehr dominant an, sieht auch sehr dominant aus. Jetzt haben wir ja aber noch ein ziemlich großes Nebenthema, nämlich in den Footballleagues spielt ja City durchaus eine unrühmliche Rolle. Hat das einen großen Einfluss auf die öffentliche Diskussion in England? Wie nimmst du das wahr?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, auch ohne diese Enthüllung ist Man City seit die Scheichs dort übernommen haben nicht gerade der beliebteste Verein in England. Selbst ja in den eigenen Reihen gab es lange kritische Stimmen oder gibt es wahrscheinlich auch noch, die sich ähnlich wie bei Manchester United, als die Glacers kamen, vom Verein abgewendet haben. Aber es ist nicht so, glaube ich, dass diese öffentliche Diskussion irgendeinen Einfluss hätte auf das Sportliche. Also die konnte, ich übertreibe jetzt, die konnte vorher keiner leiden und tut es jetzt auch. Und jetzt ist es genauso, was eben die Fans anderer Mannschaften angeht. Aber was ihnen entgegengebracht wird, ist eine Menge Respekt, wenn nicht Sympathie. Und diesen Respekt, den erarbeiten sie sich Woche für Woche durch richtig gute Leistungen. Und das jetzt schon über einen sehr langen Zeitraum, also die Rekordsaison letztes Jahr, das war phänomenal, was sie da gespielt haben. Bis hin zur 100-Punkte-Marke, die letztlich noch gesagt wurde. Und in dieser Saison geht es so weiter. Und es gibt im Prinzip nur eine Mannschaft, die verhindern kann, dass Man City Meister wird. Und das ist Man City selbst, wenn die ihr Potenzial abrufen können. Und immer wieder halt da personell aus dem Vollen schöpfen können. Und dann sitzt in Sané sogar ein wichtiges Spiel, muss man sagen. Auch öfter mal auf der Bank zunächst. Weil dann spielt eben Stirling oder Marès oder vorne Gabriel Jesus im Moment sogar verletzt. Wird aber überhaupt nicht vermisst, weil Aguero halt die Torschützenliste anführt. Und so kann man das fast für jede Position durchgehen. Das Ganze. Und es ist sogar noch Platz für einen Riesentalent wie Phil Foden, der ab und zu da auch noch mal ein paar Minuten bekommt und im Schatten der ganz Großen da heranreift. Und gerade dieses Spiel, aber wenn man das jetzt noch mal als Ausgangspunkt nimmt, warum Man City denn gewonnen hat, klar, zum einen ist jedem klar, sie haben die besseren Einzelspieler, die bessere Mannschaft. Aber sie sind eben auch mit einer ganz anderen Einstellung in das Ganze gegangen. Beide hatten drei Mittelfeldspieler aufgeboten, bei United waren es halt drei Sechser, bei Man City waren es ein Sechser und zwei Achter, die aber mehr oder weniger auch schon halbe Stürmer sind. Also inklusive der drei da vorne waren das fünf richtig Offensive und die von Anfang an eben gepowert haben und Manchester United da überhaupt nicht zur Entfaltung haben kommen lassen. Und das ist dann eben eine Sache, ein Signal, wie gehe ich ein Spiel an, personell und auch von der Einstellung, von der Taktik her. Und da sind eben dann Welten zwischen diesen beiden Mannschaften, die sich mit den Spielern auch gezeigt haben.
17 zu 6 Torschüsse für City und in dem Zusammenhang war die Statistik dann auch tatsächlich mal aussagekräftig. Hat sich denn am Spiel von City irgendwas verändert? Wir erinnern uns ja noch alle an die Pep-Jahre bei Bayern, an die von Barcelona dann schon etwas Nebel umschlungener, aber so grob im Kopf hat man es auch noch. Spielt City immer noch diesen gleichen Fußball oder gibt es da in Nuancen doch Veränderungen? Denn am Kader hat sich ja wieder, es tut sich ja immer ein bisschen was bei City, es ist immer eine Evolution.
Also sagen wir so gemessen an dem, was sie Football Leagues hin oder her kaufen könnten, haben sie eigentlich relativ wenig dann gekauft. Sie haben es jetzt punktuell verstärkt nochmal mit Maréz als weitere Alternative auf außen. Und ja, wenn man jetzt den Pep-Fußball zugrunde legt, den man kennt, dann hat er sich im Grunde von Barca über München nach Manchester nicht sehr oder nicht krass verändert. Das ist immer noch Ballbesitz-Fußball, das ist immer noch, im Prinzip, Spielen, die in 5 gegen 2, so ein Rondo, wie man es vom Warmmachen kennt, das projizieren die ständig auf den ganzen Platz. Haben also ständig Überzahl in Ballnähe, haben eine unglaubliche Passsicherheit. Danach werden Spieler, angefangen vom Torwart Ederson bis hin zum Stürmer, als eines der ersten Kriterien ausgesucht, weil sie eben diese Passsicherheit haben müssen. Und das ist die Basis des Spiels. Was sich verändert hat aber ist, dass viel zielstrebiger jetzt nach vorne gespielt wird. Und sie sind natürlich auch schwieriger auszurechnen. Und man muss dann eben auch ehrlich sagen, selbst schon zu Guardiolas Zeit in München, Robben und Ribéry sind schnell, aber Stirling und Sane sind schneller. Also sprich, da ist noch viel, viel mehr möglich und die Spielen zahlen immer wieder nach dem gleichen System. Ganz, ganz viele Pässe, dann eine Seitenverlagerung, dann ein Pass die Linie entlang, ein Rückpass in den Rücken der Abwehr. Und dann im Strafraum ist eine Präsenz von drei bis vier Leuten. Und dann kommt eine Abschlussstärke dazu. Nach diesem Muster, das man kennt, das man aber trotzdem aufgrund des Tempos nicht richtig gut verteidigen kann, oder die wenigsten Vereine können das, so fallen dann eben die Tore. Und dem beikommen kann man nur, so wie es Liverpool gemacht hat, indem man sich eben clever positioniert, indem man auch nicht komplett vorne stört, weil wenn dann die erste Linie überspielt ist, dann wird es ganz, ganz kritisch. Und deswegen hat Klopp zum Beispiel in dem Spiel neulich da auf Mittelfeldpressing gesetzt und hat sie auch erst mal kommen lassen, dann gut verdichtet. Und dann wird es eben auch schwer, diese Passtaffetten aufzuziehen gegen United. War es jetzt vor dem letzten Spiel, die Angaben schwanken zwischen 42 und 43 Pessen, bevor Gündogan dann das 3 zu 1 erzielt hat. Also sensationell, eine Mannschaft wie Manchester United, die eben hauptsächlich dann aus Defensivspezialisten bestand, das muss man ja dazu sagen, kommt 43 Mal nicht an den Ball, bevor der im Netz ist. Das ist unfassbar auf dem Niveau. Und das Spiel war ja noch offen. Es war ja nicht so, dass die kein Bock mehr hatten, weil sie 5-0 zurückklagen, sondern es stand 2-1. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, diese Spielweise. Und was Pep da, ja man kann fast sagen, geschaffen hat, das ist wirklich aller Ehren wert.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und du hast es schon angesprochen, eine der Mannschaften, die da noch so ein bisschen an Hacken von City klebt, ist eben der FC Liverpool aktuell auf Platz 2. Auch noch ungeschlagen, 2 Punkte Rückstand aktuell. Sehr, sehr gute Defensive zusammen mit City, die beste der Liga, nur 5 Gegentreffer kassiert. Wie würdest du die Situation bei Liverpool einschätzen?
Ja, zunächst mal bemerkenswert, dass sie nur 5 Gegentore auch bekommen haben wie City. Sie haben an einem Problem richtig gearbeitet und haben es gelöst, indem sie die Defensive stabilisiert haben. Da ist natürlich Van Dijk ein wesentlicher Faktor. Aber auch das ganze Defensivverhalten der Mannschaft, dadurch vor allem, wenn sie eben nicht nur auf Teufel kommen raus, da vorne presst und ständig attackiert und den Gegner jagt. Da gibt es auch Phasen im Spiel. Aber sie modifizieren das mittlerweile besser und dosieren es besser. Und dadurch treten sie auch kompakter auf und sind defensiv schlauer. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass man sich auf die drei da vorne weiterhin verlassen kann. Man merkt aber auch, es gibt Spiele wie in Belgrad, dass wenn dann nicht komplett die erste Garde auf dem Platz steht, dann mag das gegen Fulham reichen. Aber es reicht schon in der Champions League. Egal, gegen wen, offensichtlich nicht. Das ist ein Problem, dass die Kader-Tiefe da nicht so ist, wie sie eigentlich sein könnte. Sie haben natürlich noch mal einen Quantensprung gemacht. Ich habe jetzt gerade Van Dijk genannt als Abwehrchef, aber Alisson natürlich nicht zu vergessen. Das ist auch eine ganz andere Hausnummer als Carius oder Mignolet, der da hinten für Sicherheit und vor allem für Ausstrahlung sorgt, für Respekt sorgt beim Gegner. Und selbst wenn Carius und Mignolet da auch sicher vereinzelt ihre richtig guten Tage hatten, darf man nicht verschweigen, weil nur mit schlechten Torhütern kommt man nicht ins Champions League-Finale. Was da passiert ist, steht jetzt auf dem anderen Blatt. Aber grundsätzlich ist das Niveau, was Alisson da reingebracht hat, ist noch mal ein anderes. Im Mittelfeld ist natürlich Keita, der war zuletzt angeschlagen, erst wieder reingekommen. Es ist ein neuer Faktor, Fabinho tut dem Spiel gut. Shakiri ist jemand, den man fast überall bringen kann im Offensivbereich. Der eine wunderbare Technik hat, der hat halt das Pech, dass er da Salah mehr oder weniger vor sich hat auf der Seite. Wenn sie im 4-3-3 spielen und dementsprechend ist es natürlich für ihn schwierig, aber das Shakiri ist so ein Backup, den man sich wünscht und wo es dann auch keinen großen Qualitätsverlust gibt, wenn der reinkommt. Und das ist eben insgesamt in der Breite nicht so wie bei Man City der Fall. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass Liverpool da auch Strecke, vielleicht was jetzt das Titelrennen angeht, ein bisschen die Pruste ausgehen können. Aber noch sind sie mit zwei Punkten dahinter richtig gut im Rennen und haben sich das bisher auch erarbeitet und verdient.
Absolut, Na Liga, sieht das alles noch ganz gut aus. Die Niederlage bei Roter Star hast du angesprochen. Die war nicht eingeplant. Es gab so eine kleine Schwächeperiode im Pokal gegen Chelsea, zu Hause verloren, dann bei Chelsea 1 zu 1 gespielt und dann in Neapel verloren. Das waren so die schwierigsten Wochen, ergebnistechnisch, der letzten Zeit. Und damit sind wir schon relativ galant beim nächsten Club gelandet, der eben noch ungeschlagen ist, nämlich Chelsea. Die sind 4 Punkte hinter City, 2 hinter Liverpool. Warum? Sie haben einfach ein Unentschieden mehr als Liverpool und zwei mehr als City. Da sieht aber auch die Abwehr sehr gut aus, mit nur 8 Gegentreffern nach 12 Spieltagen und 27 Toren. Was ist das für ein Chelsea? Die habe ich tatsächlich ein bisschen weniger auf dem Schirm als die anderen Teams. Wahrscheinlich kommt das noch so aus von früher. Da hat es nicht besonders viel Spaß gemacht, sich Chelsea-Spiele anzugucken. Sollte ich das mal ändern, Thomas?
Unbedingt solltest du das oder auch alle anderen, die noch dem Vorurteil hinterhängen, dass Chelsea immer noch, wie zu Mourinho's Zeiten, den Doppeldeckerbus parkt. Das machen sie nämlich nicht mehr und dafür ist Maurizio Sarri halt verantwortlich, der man kann fast sagen die DNA von dieser Mannschaft verändert hat, indem er sie höher positioniert, indem er sie vor allem nach Ball gewinnt, viel, viel mutiger, viel offensiver spielen lässt. Er hat aus dem 3-4-3 oder 3-4-2-1, was er konnte, hat spielen lassen, hat er ein 4-3-3 gemacht und da gibt es zwei ganz entscheidende Faktoren. Einmal Jorginho als Sechser, der das überragend macht, sowohl Bälle gewinnt, aber auch die Angriffe selber teilweise dann schon durch frühe Stören in der gegnerischen Hälfte richtig gut dann einleitet, das Umschaltspiel. Und weil er eben jetzt Sechser ist, ist Conte, der sicherlich auch maßgeblich für Frankreichs WM-Titel war, auf die achter Position halbrechts vorgeschoben worden und einen besseren Balleroberer als den gibt es nicht. Und wenn der jetzt noch 10, 15 Meter weiter vorne spielt, generell schon, weil die Mannschaft so ausgerichtet ist, plus er selber noch weiter vorne ist, aufgrund seiner Position, dann ist kein Zufall, warum Chelsea eben im Schnitt viel weiter vorne die Bälle erobert und dementsprechend auch dann offensiver auftritt. Sarri hat davon profitiert, um es mal krass zu sagen, dass keiner wollte mehr mit Konter arbeiten, der meiner Ansicht nach dort in der ersten Saison überragende Arbeit geleistet hat, letztlich mit der Meisterschaft gekrönt.
Die konnten alle nicht mehr mit Konter, na so was.
Aber er hat dann letztlich irgendwie alles verloren, was ihn so ausgezeichnet hat. Er war nicht mehr locker, hat keinen Spaß mehr vermittelt, hat sich ständig beschwert, dass er nicht die richtigen Spieler hat. Dann hat er mit Diego Costa selber noch den besten Torschützen vergrault und so weiter. Also es wollte irgendwie keiner mehr so richtig unter ihm arbeiten. Thibaut Courtois ist regelrecht geflüchtet zur Real Madrid und da hat das Sarri von der Grundausgangsposition erstmal leicht atmosphärisch. Aber er hat genau das dann eben auch genutzt und uns sorgt eben auch für eine positive Stimmung, ist dabei aber auch ein sehr akribischer Arbeiter, der da seine seine Philosophie sehr sehr gut und schnell den Leuten vermittelt hat, nämlich dass Chelsea nicht mehr das Chelsea sein darf, dass sich hinten reinstellt und nur noch kontert, weil das eben auch der Kaderqualität überhaupt nicht gerecht wird. Ähnlich eben wie ich es vorhin bei United versucht habe zu erklären. Diese Mannschaft kann offensiver spielen, sie hat natürlich in Eden Hazard einen überragenden Spieler, ein Weltklasse Spieler, mit dem muss man ehrlich sagen auch manchmal vieles steht und fällt. Aber er ist eben da und so lange er noch da ist, macht er so wie Kante und Jorginho dann auch den Unterschied. Und Murata und Giroud sind jetzt nicht die toyiger paar Exzellentes, aber die haben beide ihre unterschiedlichen Qualitäten, die sie jetzt selten zusammen einbringen dürfen, aber jeder auf seine Weise eben wenn er spielt und von daher ist Chelsea diese Saison so gut. Ich sehe sie aber auch nicht auf dem Level von Man City, sie werden bis zum Schluss denke ich auch ein Wörtchen mitreden können, haben den Vorteil, dass sie nur Europa League spielen und da nicht so gefordert werden wie jetzt die Champions League Clubs, aber letztlich ist es schon eine richtig gute Truppe, die der Spaß macht zuzuschauen und die nicht mehr nur pragmatisch spielt, sondern eben auch den Weg nach vorne sucht und dementsprechend dafür Furore sorgt.
Die zweitmeisten Schüsse pro Spiel aufs gegnerische Tor abgegeben oder in Richtung des gegnerischen Tores, also jetzt nicht Torschüssen.
Und mehr Ballbesitz als man City sogar im aktuellen Premier League Ranking.
Absolut, unglaublich. Also da hat sich viel getan und eben bis auf eine Niederlage im Community Shield-Finale ganz am Anfang der Saison gegen City in dieser Saison noch überhaupt nicht verloren. Europa League gegen Saloniki und Vidi und Borisov, klammern wir mal aus, aber trotzdem natürlich beeindruckende Leistung, also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schaut euch Chelsea an und vielleicht ja schon am nächsten Spieltag, denn da trifft Chelsea, der Tabellenplatz 3, auf den Tabellenplatz 4, die Spurs. Wie ist denn da die Situation, Thomas, auf das Spiel kann man sich, glaube ich, freuen?
Auf das Spiel kann man sich freuen und die Spurs verraten immer eine Menge, wenn man sich nur ihre Bilanz bis Ende der Saison anschaut, nämlich null Unentschieden, neun Siege und drei Niederlagen und ich habe bewusst mit den Unentschieden angefangen, weil das dokumentiert am besten dieses Hopp oder Top, das ist Pochettino, der lässt auch mutig spielen, okay, dann verliert er halt mal drei Mal, aber hat auch schon neun Mal gewonnen und ist dann nur einen Punkt hinter Chelsea, trotz, obwohl sie drei Mal verloren haben und Chelsea noch gar nicht, liegt nur ein Punkt dazwischen und diese mutige Spielweise, die zahlt sich halt manchmal aus, manchmal müssen sie da Lehrgeld bezahlen. Der war übrigens mal bei Espanyol und hat gesagt, dass er in seinem ganzen Leben nie Barca-Trainer wird. Das finde ich sehr mutig, dass man das zu Beginn seiner Trainer-Karriere dann gleich mal so festlegt, obwohl man selber einen vielversprechenden Weg eingeht, aber nee, Barca, ihr müsst mich mal nicht anrufen. Gut, aber ihm wird es an Angeboten nicht mangelnd. Ich finde übrigens, dass der der Bundesliga sehr, sehr gut tun würde mit seiner ganzen Art, aber da ist dann eben was oft in Deutschland zu hören, ist die sogenannte Sprachbarriere und Deutsch ist so schwierig dann zu lernen und so weiter. Also es gibt ausländische Trainer, die haben es vorgemacht, dass es geht und in der Premier League sind, klar ist jetzt Englisch nicht mit Deutsch zu vergleichen als Sprache, aber trotzdem auch da muss man erstmal sich reinfinden in die Feinheiten, auch in die Feinheiten der Fußballsprache dann in dem jeweiligen Land und auch da geht es eben, dass ein Argentinier, ein Italiener, ein Deutscher und ein Spanier da oben an der Tabellenspitze sind und dementsprechend sollte man vielleicht in Deutschland dann auch öfter mal den Mut haben, einen ausländischen Trainer zu verpflichten, der nicht gleich perfekt Deutsch kann. Also nur mal so nebenbei. Ja Tottenham, um darauf zurückzukommen, so wie es bei Chelsea vieles mit Eden Hazard steht und fällt, ist es natürlich hier Harry Kane, das ist kein Geheimnis. Der hat da Zeit gebraucht, um nach der WM wieder so richtig in Schwung zu kommen. Das ist aber auch nichts ungewöhnliches für ihn zum Saisonstart und der wird seine Tore weitermachen. Jetzt ist er bei sechs Toren nach zwölf Spielen, die Quote denke ich kann er sogar noch steigern und ja ansonsten, dass die feine Fußballer haben wie Lukas oder Dele Alli oder Elamela. Loriz hat eine schwierige Saison bisher gespielt, hat in der Champions League böse gepatzt, das stehen sie ja übrigens vor dem Ausjahr.
Genau, das wollte ich mal ansprechen, ja. Gegen Mailand verloren, gegen Barca verloren und jetzt unentschieden bei Eindhoven.
Sie haben noch eine Chance durch den späten Sieg gegen Eindhoven.
Genau, das war dann das Rückspiel.
Genau. Aber das ist natürlich nicht das, was man sich dort erträumt, zumal man letztes Jahr im Achtelfinale war und dort auch tatsächlich Juventus, was glaube ich am Rande an der Niederlage hatte. Und deswegen ist die Mannschaft sicherlich zu mehr im Stande als in der Champions League geleistet hat. Aber um das noch zu Ende zu führen mit Hugo Loriz, der eben als Kapitän da auch noch als schweren Stand hat, mit Alkohol am Steuer erwischt worden und so weiter. Also das führt nicht dazu bei, dass man letztlich dann auch ein höheres Ansehen erlangt. Und da muss man dann doppelt mit Leistung sprechen lassen, um so was dann in den Hintergrund treten zu lassen. Und das ist eben in dieser Saison noch nicht so oft gelungen, wie in der vergangenen Saison zum Beispiel. Und dementsprechend muss man da, muss Tottenham sich da auch strecken. Die haben auch nicht umsonst schon doppelt so viel Gegentore, wie Liverpool und Man City kassiert, was eben aber auch ihrer, ja, ob oder top Spielweise eben geschuldet ist. Das spiegelt sich dann auch im Torverhältnis von 20 zu 10 wieder.
Absolut. Wie groß würdest du denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit einschätzen, dass der Arsenal von hinten heran rückt? Die liegen auf Platz 5, 3 Punkte hinter den Spurs und haben seit dem 3. Spieltag oder seit dem 2. Spieltag nicht mehr verloren. Auch wenn es jetzt zuletzt ein paar Unentschieden in Serie gab, aber ja unter anderem auch gegen Liverpool. Von außen betrachtet sieht das so aus, als hätte sich da langsam ein Team gefunden, ein Spielstil gefunden und das alles wird deutlich stabiler. Aber das ist jetzt nur mein externer Blick. Wie ist denn dein intimer Blick?
Ja, den kann man schon so teilen. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich schwierig, eine Mannschaft auch zu übernehmen und neu zu auszurichten, die jahrelang diesen Stil von Asien Wenger gewöhnt war. Von daher leistet Una Emery jetzt erstmal Entwicklungsarbeit. Die zwei Niederlage waren am Anfang Men's City und Chelsea, die einzigen bisher. Danach haben sie tatsächlich siebenmal gewonnen. Das war alles okay, auch ein Unentschieden gegen Liverpool. Aber dann sind natürlich solche Sachen wie jetzt zuletzt, ich glaube es war Pallas und Wulfa Hemden, jetzt mit Unentschieden. Das tut dann weh, wenn man den absoluten Sprung wieder in die Champions League Plätze schaffen will. Das sind dann Rückschläge, aber die sind dann eben auch irgendwo auf diesem Weg sicherlich einkalkuliert. Letztlich insgesamt spielt Arsenal viel erfrischender nach vorne, aber auch gleichzeitig mit mehr, die Offensivspieler kommen mehr Defensivaufgaben nach. Und da hat Emery eben was geschaffen, was bei Wenger nicht mehr war, nämlich das Füreinanderarbeiten, das Zurückarbeiten und da eben auch defensiv eine Kompakthetze erlangen, die absolut nötig ist, um nicht eben, so wie es Arsenal oft passiert ist, auseinanderzufallen in großen Spielen. Und das war jetzt da nicht der Fall bisher, sie haben auch bei Chelsea zum Beispiel einen Rückstand aufgeholt, hätten sogar auch gewinnen können das Spiel, haben zwei, drei verloren letztlich. Aber das ist schon eine andere Attitüde, die die mittlerweile da zeigen und auf den Rasen legen. Und das ist schon ein Sprung nach vorne, aber es bedarf noch Zeit. Und das, was ich vorhin über Manchester United gesagt habe, nämlich dass die ganz großen Stars den Weg dorthin nicht mehr finden, gilt natürlich mehr und mehr für Arsenal, je länger sie aus der Champions League wegbleiben. Und das ist jetzt schon das zweite Jahr. Dann müssen sie eben aufpassen, dass sie da, ich sage jetzt nicht finanziell, da ist glaube ich alles okay und da könnten sie auch noch viel mehr machen, als sie ausgegeben haben letztlich, aber dass sie eben sportlich dann den Anschluss nicht verlieren. Und so, ja, Aubameyang war unter dem, gut wir wissen alle, wie es zustande gekommen ist unter den sehr bedenklichen Umständen in Dortmund, aber das war sportlich ein richtiger Coup in der Größenordnung. Und wenn man die Mannschaft durchgeht, gibt es eben in der Kategorie nicht so viele Spieler. Und von daher müssen sie als Kollektiv eben kommen und das dann gegenüber den anderen Top-Teams kompensieren. Ich glaube, am Ende wird es aber, ja, mit viel Glück Platz 4, aber ich glaube eher wieder nur in Europa League Platz. Das hängt dann eben davon ab, wie bei Tottenham sich dieses auf und ab gestaltet. Wenn die ein bisschen mehr Konstanz rein kriegen, dann sehe ich sie stabiler und besser als Arsenal.
Ja, also Arsenal, hochinteressante Mannschaft. Es gibt nur vier Teams, die mehr Schüsse in Richtung des eigenen Tores zu lassen, mit Burnley Brighton und Fulham sowie Newcastle. Und im Expected-Points-Modell, was man natürlich nicht immer als Grundlage für alles nehmen sollte, aber da ist die Differenz so krass, da läge Arsenal eigentlich nach Expected Points auf Platz 11 und nicht auf Platz 5 wie jetzt. Also ohne da jetzt...
Rechnen die sich oder was sagen die?
Die bewerten jeden Schuss nach der Situation und der Art des Schusses, nach der Wahrscheinlichkeit, wie wahrscheinlich es ist, dass dieser Schuss ins Tor geht. Das sind dann die Expected Goals.
Also sprich, sie haben über ihre Verhältnisse eigentlich gespielt, was die...
Genau, also sprich, wenn du die Spiele, die Arsenal jetzt so gewonnen hat und mit denen Arsenal 24 Punkte geholt hat, wenn du die statistisch, sagen wir mal, nochmal eine Million mal spielen lässt, dann hätten sie in Wirklichkeit, hätten sie statistisch gesehen, hätten sie dann acht Punkte weniger geholt, als sie aktuell haben. Wie gesagt, man darf es auch nicht komplett überbewerten, aber es ist immer ein ganz guter Indikator, wenn das so weit auseinandergeht, ist es schon ein Indikator dafür, hat eine Mannschaft eher mal ein bisschen mehr Spielglück gehabt, als es normal ist. Oder auch extremes Pech, da gibt es ja auch immer wieder Mannschaften, die da schlechter dastehen. Also zum Beispiel die Wolverhampton Wanderers könnten eigentlich bei 20 Punkten stehen, das wären dann immerhin viel mehr, als sie aktuell haben und damit wären sie ja in der Liga schon deutlich weiter oben.
Also ich kannte nur Expected Goals, aber Expected Goals wird sich daraus wahrscheinlich dann ergeben.
Genau, genau. Daraus errechnet sich das dann.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig zu definieren, ganz ehrlich bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch, ob man das überbewertet sollte. Aber es ist eine schöne Spielerei.
Ja ich finde es schon interessant, wenn es so weit auseinander geht. Ansonsten nicht überbewerten und zeigt aber so ein bisschen, das hast du ja auch angedeutet, also da ist schon einiges ganz gut, der Übergang ist aber auch alles andere als einfach und sie lassen an den entscheidenden Stellen, haben sie Punkte liegen lassen und hatten eben in ein paar Partien dann eben auch das nötige Glück, da dann noch mit einem knappen Sieg dann irgendwie noch nach Hause fahren zu können. Wir haben noch zwei Teams, über die wir kurz sprechen wollen und zum einen ist das Leicester City. Das ist auch insofern wichtig, weil unsere letzte Folge jetzt schon sechs Wochen zurück liegt. Das heißt wir haben den tragischen Unfall des Besitzers von Leicester nicht mehr im Rasenfunk dokumentiert haben. Kannst du uns mal kurz reinholen, wie ist da die aktuelle Situation und vielleicht auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das damals nicht so genau mitbekommen haben, mit wem hatten wir es da eigentlich zu tun? Um wen geht es?
Ja, das war der Eigentümer von Leicester, ein Thailänder, dessen Namen ich jetzt nicht aussprechen, weil ich ihn erstens ablösen müsste und den zweitens dann immer noch keiner versteht. Der ist halt auf tragische Weise ums Leben gekommen bei einem Hubschrauber-Absturz zusammen mit vier anderen Insassen und hat da für sehr, sehr große Trauer natürlich gesorgt, dieser Vorfall, aber auch für eine, und dafür steht die Premier League auch, für eine sehr bemerkenswerte Solidarität, was da an Anteilnahme aus allen Emot-Richtungen nach Leicester letztlich geschwappt ist. Ich finde immer diese Gedenkminuten in England, die finde ich sensationell. Die unterscheiden sich von ihrem Charakter noch mal von denen in anderen Stadien dieser Welt. Es ist einfach unbeschreiblich, wenn teilweise bis zu 70.000 Leute eine Minute lang wirklich Mucks-Mäuschen still sind. Also nicht mal ein Reuspern, nichts ist irgendwo zu hören. Und das ist etwas, was diese oder auch den Remembering Day jetzt neulich in Gedenken der Kriegsgefallenen ist ja auch immer Anfang November in England. Das sind so Sachen am Rande dieser ja eigentlich nur noch dieses Business Premier League, die schon noch zeigen, was für eine große Tradition eigentlich dahinter steckt, die dann eben auch eine andere Seite offenbaren. Und für Leicester ist es natürlich jetzt schwierig, da sportlich wieder die Kurve zu kriegen. Sie haben das erste Spiel danach gewonnen. Das war auch sehr, sehr emotional, das Ganze. Wohl da das Ergebnis natürlich dann nicht so im Mittelpunkt steht bei sowas, aber letztlich ist es dann irgendwo ein Sieg für diesen Besitzer gewesen, der wohl auch eine sehr, sehr menschliche Note in den Verein reingebracht hat und da nicht kreuz und quer und sinnlos gekauft hat oder ständig Trainer geschasst hat, sondern da schon immer versucht hat, auch auf Kontinuität wertzulegen und Claudio Ranieri, der ja Meistertrainer war und dann aber entlassen wurde und so weiter, wenn man den gesehen hat auf der Tribüne, wie der da fix und fertig war, auch dann danach noch, was der für Anteil genommen hat. Das zeigt, obwohl er letztlich entlassen wurde in der Saison drauf, was da noch für eine Verbindung zu diesem Club ist und das zeigt eben, dass der Verein insgesamt sehr intakt ist und man kann sich nur wünschen, dass sich jetzt, wer immer das sein wird, irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob das familiär dann weitergeleitet wird, ob es einen ganz neuen Eigentümer geben wird, auf jeden Fall ist zu wünschen, dass Leicester sich diesen Charakter insgesamt beibehält und die war natürlich ein unscheinbarer Verein, muss man ehrlich sagen, bis zur Meisterschaft, bis sie dann 2016 in den Fokus gerückt sind von allen. Aber man verfolgt auch heute eben noch Leicester und Spieler wie Jamie Vardy und so weiter stehen für den Club oder Schmeichel im Tor und ja, denen ist einfach zu gönnen, dass sie ihren Weg da weitergehen und das Märchen werden sie nicht mehr wiederholen, müssen sie auch nicht, aber dass sie der Premier League erhalten bleiben und durch diesen heftigen, auch menschlichen Rückschlag jetzt so eng zusammenstehen, dass sie das meistern können.
Also sie sind sieben Punkte von Arsenal auf Platz 5 entfernt und neun Punkte vor der Abstiegszone, das heißt absolut im Mittelfeld gerade auf Platz 10. Da sieht es jetzt halt ganz gut aus und mit Ranieri haben wir auch schon ja die Überleitung gebaut zum letzten Verein, über den wir hier noch kurz sprechen wollen. Fulham hat einen neuen Trainer und das wird jetzt kein Hörerinnen und kein Hörer überraschen, es ist Ranieri. Was haben wir denn davon zu erwarten? Wie schätzt du das ein, Thomas?
Ja, ich denke, dass Fulham ist eigentlich nicht der typische Aufsteiger, der jetzt nach zwölf Spieltagen auf dem letzten Platz stehen müsste. Sie tun es aber, weil eben Ranieris Vorgänger es nicht so geschafft hat, da eine Einheit zu formen. Da gab es auch zwischenmenschliche, nicht so nette Töne zwischen ihm und der Mannschaft, der sich distanziert hat, so nach dem Motto, ich erkläre es ihnen halt, aber sie kapieren es nicht, so sind gemäß. Und sowas kommt dann bei einer Mannschaft natürlich nicht besonders gut an. Dann kommt natürlich hinzu, dass sie mit André Schürrle und mit Mitrovic zwei Leute, die haben zusammen neun von elf Toren geschossen. Sprich, wenn die beiden mal nicht treffen, dann ist Ebbe, dann läuft wenig.
Und die letzten vier Spiele gab es keinen Tor. Und die letzten vier Spiele gab es keinen Tor.
Ja klar, wie gesagt, wenn die da zugedeckt sind oder mal Abschlusspech haben oder sonst was, dann passiert eben nichts und dann wird es schwierig. Aber es gibt eben zwei Gründe, die einem da aus Sicht von Fulham optimistisch stimmen können, dass es jetzt wieder aufwärts geht. Weil Ranieri eben sagt oder auch forschte Töne anschlägt, er sagt jetzt nicht so ganz demütig, oh ja, um Gottes Willen, wie soll man das schaffen und jetzt erst mal ganz klein anfangen, sondern er sagt, nein, der Kader gibt eigentlich und so ist es auch mehr her. Die haben sich für 100 Millionen vor der Saison verstärkt. Da muss man jetzt nicht Understatement betreiben und es ist ja auch noch alles im überschaubaren Rahmen. Also Platz 17, Platz 16 sind drei Punkte weg, weil die alle noch nicht so richtig da in die Gänge gekommen sind. Von daher sagt er, da wollen wir jetzt schnell unten raus und mit seiner optimistischen und auch, wie ich ihn aus der Ferne einschätze, väterlichen Art wird er genau eben dieses, was zuletzt zu kurz kam, eben wieder forcieren und dann vielleicht die Mannschaft dadurch auf seine Seite bringen und wenn er Glück hat, eben das erste Spiel gegen Southampton dann gewinnt, dann sieht es dann auch schon wieder freundlicher aus. Aber von so einem Start hängt natürlich dann auch viel ab.
Wir werden es im Auge behalten. Thomas, ich danke dir. Das war jetzt ein paar Force-Rid durch alle Themen, die in der Premier League gerade so wichtig sind und im englischen Fußball generell. Das hat mir wieder große Freude bereitet. Thomas Böker vom Kicker, vielen Dank, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast, Thomas. Das freut mich und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und danke an alle die Supporterinnen und Supporter da draußen, die uns unterstützen. Der Rasenfunk bleibt werbe- und sponsorenfrei, wenn ihr uns unterstützt. rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die es jetzt schon tun. Und ansonsten hören wir uns wieder. In der nächsten Woche wird es auch noch mal einen kleinen Kurzpass geben. Thema verrate ich jetzt noch nicht. Bis dahin macht es gut, eine schöne Zeit euch.